pull de circonstance nous allons parler
des femmes des femmes d'aujourd'hui des
femmes de l'antiquité craig de leur
destin
vraiment très enviable cette vidéo
aurait pu avoir pour titre aux origines
du sla chaining mais bon vous connaissez
ma réticence face au titre dit [ __ ] la
sexy catch provoquant de rêve de toute
façon à chaque fois qu on cherche un
terme qui évoque le désir on raconte
toujours au féminin heureusement
aujourd'hui on a quelques outils pour à
la fois se faire plaisir et communiquer
avec les autres sans tomber dans un
discours culpabilisant et disqualifiants
notamment cette application que je vous
présente aujourd'hui puis jour qui
sponsorise d'ailleurs la vidéo pure et
comme une plateforme avec des annonces
en ligne où les gens partagent le type
d'expérience qu'il recherche pure est
une application de rencontre pour
explorer sa propre sexualité d'une
manière ludique sur est honnête et
briser quelques tabous au passage je me
conseille d'ailleurs de regarder leur
compte instagram si vous voulez essayer
cette application de rencontre mais que
bah vous avez peur de mal faire peur
d'être mal poli dans vos sollicitations
et c'est en fait vous allez trouver une
sorte de coach du consentement via cette
application parce que même si c'est une
application de rencontre les règles du
vivre ensemble et de la loi tout
simplement s'applique alors vous allez
voir que la vidéo qui suit montre qui
n'est absolument pas question de ça dans
l'antiquité oublier le consentement et
la liberté on va voir que les relations
sont la plupart du temps très inégale en
deux laissant la place à des fantasmes
masculins les femmes sont bien souvent
un instrument dans les mains des hommes
pour leur prestige ou leur plaisir alors
les nude de l'époque si vous voulez on
les retrouve sur les céramiques 1 et on
n'est clairement pas dans le partage
mais plutôt dans la soumission donc on
peut se réjouir aujourd'hui d'avoir à
disposition des moyens techniques qui
laisse la liberté d'exposer la diversité
des désirs dont je vous invite à les
découvrir curapp si ça vous tente et
puis bah on enchaîne sur le sujet du
jour
[Musique]
on a déjà tout dit de la grèce antique
larchitecture la philosophie la
démocratie la mythologie et je m'y suis
collé d'ailleurs des milliers de livres
d'histoire ont été écrits sur cette
civilisation et le vème siècle avant
jésus-christ est souvent citée comme un
merveilleux âge d'or depuis plusieurs
siècles l'analyse des très nombreux
textes conserver a permis de connaître
dans les moindres détails l'histoire
grecque antique récit guerre réformes
politiques résultats de concours
sportive traités scientifiques
déroulement de cérémonie religieuse tout
nous apparaît avec la plus grande clarté
un petit détail près
la vie des femmes
car quand on veut parler des femmes du
passé on est tout de suite confronté à
une difficulté de taille c'est le nombre
de source des femmes des périodes
anciennes n'écrivent pas pour la grèce
on a bien quelques fragments de poèmes
de sapho mais c'est tout quelques
centaines de mots tout au plus faire une
histoire des femmes revient donc à
essayer de déceler dans les propos des
hommes les informations plus ou moins
idéalisée sur leurs mères leurs filles
et leurs épouses ou leur maîtresse
ajoutons à cela que les historiens
jusqu'au milieu du xxème siècle était
presque uniquement des hommes donc pas
forcément sensibilisé à la question et
vous obtenez une absence totale de
connaissance sur la moitié féminine de
la population même si l'histoire des
femmes est longtemps restée une
sous-discipline de l'histoire
généralistes penser comme masculine
aujourd'hui l'étude des rapports entre
hommes et femmes a souvent sa place dans
les livres d'histoire on l'a donc laissé
de côté les hommes pour une fois essayé
de cerner entre les lignes le quotidien
des femmes de l'antiquité grecque
[Musique]
puisqu'il ya 2500 ans les femmes
grecques n'écrivait pas lorsqu'elles
sont mentionnés par les sources elles le
sont avant tout en précisant leur
relation aux hommes de manière générale
les femmes sont le support de 3 types de
relations elle donne des héritiers d
alliance sociale ou du plaisir
la première et la deuxième fonction sont
confondus dans une institution spéciale
le mariage tandis que la troisième
fonction et on le verra souvent
distinctes avant de poursuivre je vous
invite si vous le souhaitez à soutenir
la chaîne via your type ou aussi viano
bpn avec ce code affilié passé sauvage
vous avez droit à une réduction de 70%
sur les abonnements annuels mensuels je
ne sais plus les infos sont dans la
barre d'information ça vous permet
d'être à la fois tendance parce que
c'est très tendance d'avoir un vpn et de
soutenir passé sauvage ce qui est aussi
une grosse tendance 2021 2022
[Musique]
le mariage est en fait à un acte entre
deux hommes par l'intermédiaire d'une
femme c'est une alliance entre le père
et son gendre qui se mettent d'accord
sur une dot c'est à dire sur le prix du
mariage c'est aussi un acte public qui
concerne la cité car l'objectif du
mariage et la procréation légitime de
nouveaux citoyens la femme stérile est
ainsi considérée comme inutile incapable
d'accomplir sa fonction première
la maternité est en effet une obligation
pour les pousses de citoyens c'est une
manière de sécuriser sa position puisque
l'absence de descendance peut conduire
les poux à la répudier pour prendre une
autre épouse mais donner naissance est
un moment particulièrement dangereux
nombre de femmes n'y survivent pas
euripide fait dire à m'aider dans la
tragédie du même nom qu'il est
préférable de monter aux combats que
d'accoucher et cette analogie entre
combats et accouchement est parfois
faite de manière officielle à ce parc
les seuls habitants qui ont le privilège
de voir inscrit leur nom sur leurs
sépultures sont les hommes morts au
combat et les femmes mortes en couches
l'enfantement et donc la mission civique
de la femme l'élément central de la
condition féminine en grèce antique pour
remplir cette mission les filles sont
mariées très tôt à peine adolescente
l'âge minimal semble être autour de 12
ans même si aristote par exemple
recommande un mariage aux alentours de
18 ans pour éviter que les grossesses
trop précoce ne soient mortels à partir
de leur mariage les femmes connaissent
plus que la maison et leur mari le
fourneau et le métier à tisser sont bien
souvent leur seul horizon la cuisine et
petit singe constituent en effet
l'occupation par excellence de les
pouces l'activité du tissage est
d'ailleurs très souvent utilisés sur les
décors céramique pour symboliser les
activités féminines la naissance d'une
petite fille à athènes et même signalé
par la suspension d'un brin de l'aisne
au dessus de la porte du foyer une
manière de rappeler ce qui l'attend plus
tard c'est une tâche répétitive et
fatigante qui nécessite de nombreuses
étapes nettoyage de la laine cardage
peignage sillage puis enfin tissage de
les toffes seule la teinture est confiée
à des spécialistes est réalisé en dehors
de la maison
nourrir le foyer n'est pas non plus une
mince affaire le traitement des grains
stockés dans les réserves est long et
pénible grillage mouture pétrissage
cuisson la femme qui pétrit le pain est
dans les textes un leit motiv de
l'épousé dévouée les hommes ne s'occupe
de cuisine que pour les sacrifices
religieux hors du foyer aller chercher
l'eau au puits et fontaine est aussi une
tâche exclusivement féminine comme le
suggère l'iconographie sans doute plutôt
assigné aux esclaves voilà pour un
rapide tour d'horizon de la vie des
femmes mariées pas forcément trépidant
mais ce statut matrimonial leur garantit
au moins une protection légale que
d'autres n'ont pas
on exige des épouses grecque la fidélité
à leurs maris les femmes adultères sont
exclus des cérémonies publiques et
humilié elles n'ont plus le droit de
porter de bijoux sous peine d'être
frappé mais pour les hommes les
relations extraconjugales sont autorisés
à condition que cela n'ait pas lieu sous
son toit ni avec l'épousé d'un autre
citoyen la plupart de ces relations sont
arrivés et concernent des femmes
esclaves ou de condition très modeste
les prostituées sont des nommés par le
mot de portails dérivé du verbe vendre
c'est un terme péjoratif bien qu'elles
soient considérées d'utilité publique à
athènes les lois de solon au vième
siècle avant jésus-christ met en avant
cette utilité pour légaliser les maisons
de passe le gouvernement athéniens fait
rassembler les prostituées des rues et
les installe dans des maisons ouvertes à
tous les dictées riols cette réforme est
conçu comme une manière de gérer les
pulsions des jeunes gens et d'éviter
qu'ils ne viennent convoité les jeunes
filles de bonnes familles en attente
d'un mariage ou même les femmes déjà
marié les bordels sont donc un moyen de
conserver l'ordre social et de minimiser
les sources de conflits entre citoyens
le prix de la passe est réglementée à un
tarif très bas une obole cela permet de
rendre ce service public accessible au
plus grand nombre et la cité ne se prive
pas de prélever une taxe au passage le
port nikon dans le cadre d'un banquet la
prostitution peut prendre des formes
plus sophistiqués musique conversations
les femmes sont amenés à user d'autres
charmes mais là encore le service de
celle qu'on nomme et haïr est encadrée
et ne peut pas excéder 2 drachme
certains hommes entretiennent aussi une
concubine qui le dès lors plus payer à
la passe mais salariés en quelque sorte
dans la haute société elles sont traités
avec soin par leurs protecteurs pour
qu'il entretient d'une amie de coeur et
signes ostentatoires de richesse le
modèle par excellence et aspasie la
compagne de périclès à qui on a prêté
une influence non négligeable sur le
stratège athéniens jusque dans la
conduite de la guerre du péloponnèse ses
concubines et autres femmes monnayant
leur charme se devait de ne pas être en
simple pour ne pas perdre leur valeur
les grecs de l'antiquité ne pratique pas
la contraception mais elles ont recours
à l'avortement notamment en sautant de
manière répétée et violente pour faire
ceux décrochés l'embryon les femmes le
pratiquent aussi en ingérant des potions
aux propriétés abortives mais cette
méthode est dangereuse et beaucoup en
heure empoisonné
on le voit qu'elles soient et plus de
citoyens ou de plus basse extraction les
femmes grecques subissent un modèle
patriarcal rigide mineurs aux yeux de la
loi les femmes même appartenant aux
grandes familles sont privés des droits
les plus élémentaires toute femme est
d'ailleurs censé avoir un représentant
légal un querios il s'agit du mari du
frère du père ou à défaut du parent
masculin le plus proche ce tuteur se
chargent les actes juridiques ou
économiques puisque les femmes dont
aucune autonomie en la matière et femmes
n'ont par exemple pas la possibilité
d'hériter à athènes si un homme meurt en
ne laissant qu'une fille et pas de fils
cette fille devient épique l'air c'est à
dire qu'elle sert de relais au
patrimoine jusqu'au prochain héritiers
mâles mais elle n'hésite pas elle même
une femme mariée devenant épique l'air
doit donc divorcer de son mari pour
épouser son plus proche parent mal et
ainsi rapatrier les biens de son père au
sein de la famille la loi athénienne
interdit par ailleurs aux femmes de
négocier des sommes supérieures à une
médine d'orge c'est à dire la quantité
nécessaire pour une famille pour une
semaine cela leur laisse la possibilité
de mener un petit commerce d'artisanat
et de veiller aux achats du quotidien
mais leur interdit en revanche la
gestion de biens de grande valeur le
contrôle des femmes est perceptible
jusque dans l'architecturé des maisons
grecque avec une entrée unique et une
cour intérieure elle permet de
surveiller facilement les allées et
venues en particulier pour éviter que
les femmes de la maison ne soit en
contact avec des hommes venus de
l'extérieur les femmes ne sont par
exemple pas censés croiser les
compagnons de banquet du chef de famille
dans certains contrats de mariage
d'époque tardive on prévoit par écrit
que les pouces n'a pas droit de
s'absenter de chez elle
de jour comme de nuit sans
l'autorisation de son mari
l'idéal féminin grecque restons
définitive pénélope les pousses du lys
attendant sagement son retour pendant 20
ans dans la plus stricte chasteté
réclusion travail domestique et fidélité
voilà le modèle imposé xénophon l'auteur
de l'économique à un manuel pour bien
tenir son foyer explique le rôle des
femmes par la nature
quant à la femme la divinité lui a créé
un corps moins résistants aussi elle me
semble avoir chargé des travaux de la
maison aristote justifié lui aussi les
rapports entre hommes et femmes par la
nature la relation du mal à la femelle
est par nature celle de supérieurs et
inférieurs de gouvernants à gouverner
dans la mythologie même ce modèle est
énoncé le mythe de création de la femme
est racontée par les young dans sa
théorie de ce fait fabriquer pandora par
héphaïstos pour se venger du vol du feu
par prométhée c'est de celle là qui est
sorti la race l'engeance maudite des
femmes terrible fléau installé au milieu
des hommes
pandora libère tous les maux sur
l'humanité et avec elle la race des
femmes oblige les hommes à la
reproduction sexuée à la naissance et
donc à la mort femme égale malédiction
une idéologie bien rodée et qui a
persisté bien au delà l'antiquité
[Musique]
mais au-delà de ce modèle rigide les
sources nous faut aussi entrevoir une
réalité souvent plus souple il ne faut
pas oublier que les textes antiques sont
bien souvent normatif c'est à dire qu'il
cherche à énoncer un modèle et décrivent
la société telle qu'elle devrait être
mais on possède aussi des documents plus
discret et pita funéraire comptes rendus
de procès ou même dédicace de monuments
rats les amis
1 et des travaux
allez
laissez moi bosser
laissez-moi
enregistrer ma vidéo
ces sources nuance la vision très ferme
et qu'on vient de décrire les femmes
grecques qui apparaissent par exemple
avec un rôle économique important elles
sont à la tête d'une véritable unité de
production domestique composé de
plusieurs esclaves dans les familles
riches grâce au produit de leur travail
qui peut être vendu à l'extérieur les
femmes participent à la prospérité du
foyer le principe de confinement des
femmes à l'intérieur montre lui aussi
beaucoup de limites c'est sans doute
vrai pour les riches citoyens mais dans
les faits la pauvreté aboli les
barrières du genre le fonds commun
méditerranéen penche plutôt pour une
séparation des espaces fréquentés par
les femmes et les hommes sans doute plus
réaliste que la réclusion décrit par les
membres de l'élite dans les foyers
pauvres l'activité des femmes à
l'extérieur est en effet indispensable
pour compléter les revenus du mari les
femmes libres vente donc souvent leur
production sur le marché et offrent
objets d'artisanat plantes médicinales
etc à athènes les femmes de citoyens
sont toutefois interdits de vente du
poisson ou de tenir des bains publics
des activités qui sont jugées
dégradantes on a finalement des mentions
de femmes ayant exercé de nombreux
métiers parmi eux le métier de
sage-femme et le plus valorisé les
femmes de citoyens peuvent le pratiquer
sans restriction d'autant plus qu'ils
s'exercent dans l'intimité d'une maison
et pas dans la rue fait d'arrêter la
nerthe socrates était elle-même sages
femmes certaines en viennent à posséder
de véritables connaissances de médecins
gynécologues
c'est le cas de fans aux strates et
femmes athénienne connu grâce à sa stèle
funéraire qui rend hommage à sa qualité
de sages-femmes et de médecins
dans les milieux modestes les femmes
peuvent également être employés dans les
champs même si c'est théoriquement
réservés aux hommes lors des récoltes
demandant beaucoup de main d'oeuvre la
présence des femmes est attesté
notamment pour le glanage des épis
tombés au sol un travail
particulièrement pénible des campagnes
guerrières ayant lieu l'été qui est la
saison des combats pour les grecs le
recours aux femmes paraît indispensable
pour mener à bien les travaux des champs
en l'absence des hommes
finalement il faut bien constater que
les fans de l'antiquité grecque nous
apparaissent à travers un miroir
déformant la grande majorité des sources
qui ne sont pas revenus sont d'origine
athénienne et ce prisme est sans doute
un peu réducteur les rares fois où l'on
possède d'autres sources de spartoo de
crète par exemple elles permettent
souvent de nuancer les pratiques
athénienne assez rigide il ne faut pas
oublier que les sources souffre aussi
d'un billet social important elle nous
parle un peu des femmes de citoyens
mêler mes textes à dire les étrangères
et les esclaves sont invisibles par
ailleurs les femmes décrites dans les
oeuvres artistiques dans le théâtre en
particulier doivent être appréhendés
avec un regard critique car il s'agit de
représentations stéréotypées pour faire
ressortir leur caractère comique ou
tragiques d'autant plus que les
personnages de femmes sont jouées au
théâtre par des hommes ce qui conduit à
exagérer les stéréotypes de genre
d'ailleurs pour l'anecdote des hommes
portent des masques blancs la couleur de
peau des femmes qui sont reclus des
voies peu le soleil tandis que les
hommes sont réputés avoir la peau foncée
dans les témoignages de justice aussi
les femmes qui apparaissent dans les
affaires familiales sont cantonnés à des
rôles stéréotypés la bonne épouse la
maîtresse ingrate la veuve courageuse et
c'est là encore la parole est aux hommes
et ne reflètent que les quelques
archétypes féminins communément admis
même dans l'iconographie et malgré la
diversité des scènes peintures les
céramiques par exemple la figure
féminine reste archétypale on ne
représente jamais les femmes dans un
ouvrage pénible ni les vieilles femmes
ou encore les maires s'occupant
d'enfants en bas âge c'est toujours un
imaginaire social de la femme qui se
donne à voir
chercher un portrait réaliste des femmes
dans les sources masculine est souvent
peine perdue cela nous renseigne
toutefois sur le paysage social dans
lequel elle était inséré la cité ce club
d'hommes comme disait pierre vidal
naquet ne parle finalement des femmes
que pour préciser l'usagé qu'en font les
hommes il y a en conclusion deux écueils
à éviter faire des femmes des créatures
totalement soumise au contrôle des
hommes et n'intervenant pas du tout dans
la société ou au contraire généralisée
les rares exemples d'émancipation en
minimisant le cadre patriarcale 7 places
attribuées aux femmes et cette
rhétorique de la grèce il ya 2500 ans
nous la connaissons en fait très bien
elle n'est finalement pas très éloignée
de ce qu'on rencontrait encore en europe
au début du 20e siècle l'émancipation
des femmes n'a à peine que quelques
dizaines d'années et encore beaucoup de
chemin à parcourir
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu vous
pouvez mettre un pouce bleus la partager
la commenter donc on a vu aussi la
stigmatisation des femmes et celle de
leur sexualité est encore bien présente
dans la majorité des sociétés les
nouvelles technologies ont leur rôle à
jouer là-dedans une application quand
même piur permet notamment aux femmes de
décider de leur sexualité comme bon leur
semble d'avoir la responsabilité de leur
corps et des images qu'elle diffuse puis
au rap est une interface qui reste très
vigilante sur le contenu des messages
pour permettre à des gens honnêtes de se
rencontrer en toute bienveillance et
c'est pour cette raison qui m'a semblé
intéressant de vous en parler dans cet
épisode je vous remercie je remercie
pions ap de leur confiance vous
trouverez sous la vidéo des informations
supplémentaires sur cette application de
rencontre et moi je vous dis à la
prochaine salut
[Musique]